you
greetings from the Garden of Good and
Evil uncle Joey here I'm voting day
that's what you wanna do stand online
for four [ __ ] hours like an [ __ ]
see a little sticker so you could show
your friends at Starbucks look at me I
voted you [ __ ] [ __ ] don't you know
this thing's already been won decided
they already got it in the bag who gives
a [ __ ] the only [ __ ] should be
voting for today is you [ __ ] cuz you're
the Captain Kirk Lee your enterprise and
you gonna rouse is there present when
you go to your supermarket is there
president dad know when you gonna dock
there was there present then know when
you're [ __ ] cashing your check after
they take 90 [ __ ] in the house and taxes
on a judge president and know you're the
[ __ ] that's got a deal with put
the recipes in man
oh my god we can't wait get the [ __ ] out
of here there's more important things
[ __ ] going on your life do you know
like what like you and what you're gonna
do your next [ __ ] move people buying
into the river she's the first lady
president oh go [ __ ] yourself when
you're later than [ __ ] casket and
you're thinking about your life you
can't be thinking about if you voted for
uncle how much more made more friends
you had because of Hillary and all this
[ __ ] these people are [ __ ] [ __ ]
do you know that have you ever thought I
mean they cannot be this stupid if you
want to vote for Joe Stein and are you
fine uncle but the two of these people
the one guys are celebrity I mean you
can't get mad at a guy the guy it's like
me running for president in 90 days I'm
gonna say some stupid [ __ ] dude cuz I'm
a [ __ ] idiot okay should have kept
his mouth shut and put a [ __ ] politic
hose around and he would have been fine
because who the [ __ ] Hilary is the
wrath of God you ever gonna eat
somebody's [ __ ] and it's black deep
down inside that's the spirit of [ __ ]
Hillary Clinton dawg she's not a woman
so if you're a woman in your fall for
this you'd actually gave you more [ __ ]
hugs take the hat off and your [ __ ]
sandals in that air of life owes you
something cuz you suck twenty dicks and
get your [ __ ] together next time I got
[ __ ] says some to you stabbed in the
neck you do mafia womanhood then some
[ __ ] wrote in for Hillary Clinton
and now important issues Russians and we
got this [ __ ] town that's a lot two
weeks old
that's are gonna expired right to the
given X by advice and you will [ __ ] man
you understand me people trying to
[ __ ] call me they don't know I'm
[ __ ] taking this to the next level
you understand today what's thirty seven
years since my mother's been dead but I
have to tell you some guys with all the
[ __ ] I talked and whatever be [ __ ]
with me yesterday so you guys gotta do
me a [ __ ] favor today you guys got to
do something for me that would mean the
[ __ ] world to me is when we get off
this periscope call your mom tell her
listen uncle Joey says to tell him that
I [ __ ] love you mom there's you know
what man my mom's been out for 37 years
and it's still the paint's still [ __ ]
lateness it's like the to take after you
take [ __ ] to tylenols
the pain still there but yeah the pain
is gone but the remnants is dead so do
me a favor today I respect funk with
Joey Diaz right whether you like me and
I don't give a [ __ ] if you don't like me
but this wrong telling you is the truth
and whether you like me or not you got
accepted
it's your mama's kind dog you don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on your route
okay you walk around you laugh you smile
you learn come on but so do me a favor I
respect whether you [ __ ] hate my
[ __ ] [ __ ] fat ass boy y'all both yes
this is periscope ends boy your mom
trust me same on your bad ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] and just hang about she understand
you made her [ __ ] that there's the
time of year where people get [ __ ] up
with darts and you know things ain't
working your way who gives a [ __ ] it's
all gonna get better for you trust long
Tonya man trust me I'm Tanya there was a
time when for years this time we used to
destroy me I'd call but to [ __ ] the
Sun but just kill you don't let it do it
it did don't let it you know you do it
hang out with your friends smoking
reefer do some exercising keep your mind
not get behind read a book whack off
whatever the [ __ ] don't get into that
[ __ ] holiday depression because you
know all people it ain't worth it it
ain't worth it it's just one two month
period and next thing you know February
you get your dick sucked midgets of
licking [ __ ] and you're sitting there
going who's better than me
[Laughter]
I don't know if you guys guys notice all
that this is the best part of my day
when I just sit here with you [ __ ]
almost and we smoke a bowl don't cost
you nothing don't cost me none it's just
real [ __ ] talking [ __ ] yeah I'm
saying and that's it and that's that
flops what's Saturday because [ __ ]
Wilbur's sold out that getting at an
extra show so we have Foxwoods on
Wednesdays from yothe Saturday the 12th
I know the UFC's um but here's the
ticket show starts at 7:30 were out of
it like my 9:30 we'll catch the last
[ __ ] fight at the bar that's how we
do it costs up to bring you a reefer
bring your ass and bring heroin I don't
give a [ __ ] what you got we're gonna
have a good old [ __ ] time tonight the
church what's happening now read a clock
we're gonna rock and roll and I'm
talking [ __ ] having a good time but it's
awesome a goddamn heart now you're
dealing with [ __ ] Tuesday what are
you gonna do go get it so [ __ ] let these
morons stand online you still gotta do
what you gotta do you got goals
you got a daily plan and you got a smoke
reefer Reef has always got to be in that
agenda you don't make those
you do it by yourself you know you go to
some bar hang out with a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and tell them your thoughts on the
election who gives a [ __ ] about your
doors you [ __ ] [ __ ]
your thoughts are you so [ __ ]
intelligent if you know anything about
politics you wouldn't be talking about
politics because perhaps this is about
stealing that's it it's about [ __ ]
white dudes getting their dicks up and
stealing your [ __ ] paper and building
construction and then making money that
way and meanwhile you're here listen
wait about one person itself and you'll
be a lot better off what do you think we
smoking on the bowl while we tap out
like a bunch of having sex me I say we
smoke a bong cos if you're walking on
ice you might as a little - on this damn
they know used to hanging out with uncle
Joey if you're not gonna take you to the
final [ __ ] frontier
very nice I like you people I like when
we get together we have chit chats on
what nut I'm a crazy [ __ ]
I got felony as well stuff how hartney
balls and listen I've been in worse
positions that you've ever even dreamed
of but you know what I'm here I got a
wife I got a kid so obviously I stuck to
a [ __ ] plan the plan is the most
important thing a man without a plan is
not a [ __ ] man Nietzsche said
that so do yourself a favor write out
what the [ __ ] you want and go for it and
then a year live that same piece of
paper you're gonna think Uncle Joe and
you start breaking Milan crises
everything you run on that paper the ten
things you wrote you'd have seven of
them and that you could get the bowl of
life and smoke it I said [ __ ]
see you tonight eight o'clock Church or
what's happening now whether you're
there or not we're taking it to the hoop
so make sure you're [ __ ] there [ __ ]
the election report what did I tell you
don't worry you know
stay black boy if that mom and my being
a lawyer said it